[Musik]
so jetzt immer fertig das ist unser
garten hier
wir haben hier wirklich einiges gemacht
sei es ein gartenhäuschen gebaut neben
der besserung sun lage eingebaut die
zisterne eingebaut alles komplett
automatisch mit dem kompletten smart
home system ein richtig cooles system
dass ich mehr zeit habe den garten auch
zu genießen
das heißt ich muss nicht mehr verbessern
mit dem schlauch mache ich jetzt habe
ich gerne es muss auch zugeben dass ich
gerne ab und zu trotzdem schlauch nicht
einfach weil es einfach liebe pflanzen
zu bewässern
aber es geht auch mal tage wohl nicht da
bin oder einmal im urlaub sind und es
wird trotzdem alles bewässert sein ich
möchte eine komplette kontrolle in
meinen garten haben ich möchte wissen
welche pflanze braucht den wasser und
das habe ich mir jetzt alles abgenommen
indem ich ein richtig cooles system
gemacht habe zusammen im rheiner von
gardena weil erste absolut profilen hat
mir das beigebracht und ich hoffe dass
solches video gefällt schaut euch mal an
wie wir alles gestanden haben was für
besondere hacks und tipps und tricks wir
dann gemacht haben und ja und jetzt
kommt ein paar zusammen den garten
genießen wir noch unkraut zupfen ernten
und die bäume zurechtschneiden und das
ist für mich einfach ein geniales gefühl
schaut sich an als aller ist müsst ihr
wissen dass es in deutschland eine
oberflächenwasser gebühr gibt es ist die
gebühr für regenwasser ist aufs dach
fällt und dann in die kanalisation
eingebracht wird dafür verlangt der
staat natürlich steuern und um diese
steuern zu umgehen habe ich mir gedacht
als schwabe hegau doch mit system
das heißt das ganze wasser vom dach wird
komplett in eine zisterne eingeleitet
das ist wie so ein großer wasserspeicher
womit ich später kostenlos beim ganzen
garten bewässern kann um die zisterne zu
füllen ist der erste schritt einfach wir
legen kg rohre und zwar hier seht ihr
die konnten das regenwasser runter vom
dach und vom dach wird es dann direkt
ins system weitergeleitet
[Musik]
natürlich ab und zu mal die wasserwaage
hingeben kann man sieht erstmal ein
gefälle hat
und hier könnt ihr sehen wie ganzen kg
vorlegen bis 4 fort die zisterne und
diese szene ungefähr 20.000 liter
fassungsvermögen und das hört sich jetzt
viel an 20.000 dieser ist aber wirklich
bei dieser dachfläche eigentlich groß
und dann bin ich wirklich total
unabhängig vom normalen hausanschluss
vom haus wasser und kann man mich durch
meine jetzt ist endlich mein eigen
gesammeltes wasser den ganzen garten zu
bewässern und ist ganz ganz coole
geschichte
also das heißt wenn ihr zu hause
wirklich mal baut bitte vergiss die
zisterne nicht nein ist man natürlich
nicht mit den händen ich warte bis der
bagger kommt und dann meist mit dem
bagger
jetzt haben wir das loch 40 stelle
ausgegraben komplett und es habe ein
problem wie komme ich aus dieser gruppe
wieder raus
macht es zu hause nicht nach
das war ein schwäbischer aufzug genauso
leicht auf dem bau
wer jetzt keine kamera dabei würden
durch den punk jetzt mit der hand
runterlaufen nur drei sätzen aber das
war natürlich arbeitsschutz mäßig war
das falsch deswegen war das heute nicht
deswegen wenn man den bagger nehmen und
in bahrain lobten aber wie gesagt ja
praktisch ganz leicht normalerweise
könnte ich dann einfach so rein merken
aber heute nicht
[Musik]
die zisterne ist jetzt drin und jetzt
noch eine seite wieder zuschütten gucken
dass alles im wasser liegt das alles
eben nicht um alles zu schütten und das
ist jetzt mein tank mit dem ich den
ganzen garten bewässern werden mit
regenwasser
jetzt sind schon eine grundsteinlegung
unseres gartens und zwar am besten ist
wenn man es nicht von vornherein plan
wohin meine nutzpflanzen wo habe ich den
garten wo habe ich zierpflanzen wo habe
ich rasenfläche und ich möchte die
rasenfläche bewässern und ihr kennt es
natürlich habt ja schon öfters gesehen
so eine sprinkleranlage und diese
sprinkleranlage die werden wir jetzt im
reinhardt der ist auch da rein kommt
zeigt ich mal ganz kurz
erst das erste besserung techniker und
mit ihm zusammen mache ich es wir werden
jetzt versuchen oder versuchen heißt gut
wir machen diese sprinkleranlage wahl
einsetzen
und jetzt tun wir gerade an zeichnen wo
wir überall diese sprinkler aufstellen
damit nachhaltig verrohrungen machen
müssen und zwar müssen sich alle
vorstellen dass da hier ist ungefähr die
grasnarbe die ich so hoch und jetzt
müssen wir uns mal 30 zentimeter runter
und nachher wird das ding hier
aufgesetzt und dann kommt es raus
ungefähr so und hier kann man natürlich
auch einstellen ist eine ganz coole
sache ich möchte euch ganz kurz zeigen
uns hier oben kannst du zum beispiel die
wassermenge und den radius einstellen
und dann geht es gerade in diesem winkel
grad hier rum und außen rum und ich kann
hier stets auch drauf fünf bis acht
meter bewässert das heißt das ding
schießt fünf bis acht meter raus je nach
einstellung das kann man auch nachher
einstellen und jetzt soll diese
sprinkleranlage überall einsetzen und
machen jetzt nachher noch die förderung
also wir jetzt überall anzeichnen
vorüber da über eine sprinkleranlage
reinkommt und damit die verordnung
geklagt nachdem man hier hinsetzen der
muss im prinzip diesen halbkreis
beregnen okay das heißt wir müssen
politik hier hinsetzen
[Musik]
und ohne planten garten zu machen ist
wirklich eigentlich wie soll ich sagen
eigentlich abenteuer deswegen immer von
vornherein plan zu machen wohl dass man
weiß wo was sie genervt
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir überall wo die
sprinkleranlagen sind haben wir ja über
land gezeichnet und jetzt gerade bände
im bagger gräbt er gerade 30 zentimeter
ungefähr unter die grasnabe die nachher
hier sein wird hat er jetzt den ganzen
wieso sagen wieso ein labyrinth gemacht
und da gehen jetzt die ganzen
versorgungsleitungen durch und wir
werden jetzt einfach die
versorgungsleitungen legen und die
versorgungsleitungen
zudem springt anlagen die den emotionen
ventilen das war das wird tonne seien
beim gartenhäuschen und das sind die
ventile und die ventile die steuern dann
einfach wann wasser gespritzt werden
soll oder man nicht ja und da sind jetzt
gerade wie gesagt dabei das hat das
auszugraben oder wenn macht es mit
bagger mit der hand des zu machen es ist
unmöglich sommer noch jetzt ist es
material gekommen und zwar hier sind
diese versorgungsleitungen drin und
diese versorgungsleitungen das sind
spezielle kunststoffrohre und jetzt gibt
es einen kleinen trick den aber jetzt
rainer verraten
und zwar ist es ganz einfach wir werden
jetzt diese versorgungsleitungen in der
sonne haben jetzt erstmal ausbreiten
dann werden wie warm und dadurch geht
auch der drei raus und da können wir
einfach besser damit arbeiten und da
muss man echt aufpassen beim auslegen
dass da kein knick reinkommen aber wenn
man knick reinkommt dann solltet ihr
vielleicht ist sie gerade abschneiden
beim skadi nachher bin da einfach
zusammen verbinden dann ist es gar kein
problem
den habe ich jetzt absolut rein gemacht
richtig kraft oder wahnsinn so eine
kurze pause muss natürlich auch noch
sein sohn griffin dunne rhein gekippt
ja aber wenn ich jetzt bin ich jetzt es
wird wenn man es nur heißen der kleine
dicke stau beim essen stellt das ist ja
wohl nicht drum cafe ja und dann gehen
wir weiter oder dann läge moore rein
okay nicht sogar nur milch nur milch nur
mich okay
schwarz-weiß sind heißt wieder sehr
kleine dinge weiß dass ich immer kleine
dicke kein wasser sauber reinhard die
burschen da wohl doch nicht nur ein
kaffee holen oder stimmt hey es ist
schon 20 nach 1 mein problem
der kommt mir vergangen das wird nix
mehr machen halt ohne kaffee hier sind
in der terrasse abu salim und die videos
dreht ist übrigens da ja die ich da okay
gemacht natürlich auf weiß nicht warum
aber auf jeden fall auf jeden fall tun
wir hier auch außen rum pflanzen machen
und dass man da nicht dauernd gießen
muss dann machen wir ein tropfen auf
einen topf schlauch das habt ihr
vielleicht auch schon oft gesehen ist
einfach ein schlauch mit lauter löchern
drin und da kommt mir im niedrigen druck
einfach so tröpfchenweise wasser raus
und somit werden die pflanzen eigentlich
direkt begossen richtig männer können
wir nicht zustimmen
ja so ist es soll jetzt sowohl die
ganzen leitungen legen und die ganzen
leitungen legen wir wirklich immer zu
den ventilen und die ventile werden
eingespeist und systeme richtig richtig
super wenn wir weiter wir legen jetzt
das rollen den graben rain dogs und da
muss man aufpassen dass man hier keine
kleine rein kriegen wenn es zu eng ich
muss man mit mel verbinde name im alter
ansonsten kann muss wie hier jetzt recht
gut hier einfach in den graben und
irgendwie auch das klima hinter dieser
relativ flexibel
h
[Musik]
man muss sich ja voll ins zeug
aber es macht richtig spaß oder herr
spaß ja wahnsinnig spaß du ich könnte
nichts anderes machen den ganzen tag
ach gott hast du jeu du foulard so wie
du schaffst du mich die man urlaub
machen
[Musik]
und wenn es schneidet mit dem schlauch
schneiden müssen dann nicht sowie
ungefähr strippen dass einmal 20
europäischen schnitt es ist ein reiner
aus wernborn als wahnsinn so als links
haben wir dies verbinde und diese
verbindung ist nicht ganz einfach sich
mal und zwar gibt es dann trick und zwar
bei den cardenas ist es so bei den
verbindungen sind zwei widerstände und
zwar gehst du einmal rein zeige ich euch
kurz einen widerstand und zeigte zwei
der widerstand und jetzt kupplung zu
drehen und das war es eigentlich schon
so einfach rein kupplung auf einen
widerstand 2 die widerstand und kupplung
wieder zu perfekt
[Musik]
ganz wichtig ist wenn man das macht dass
man auch die schläuche die man zudem
entfielen zieht auch immer kennzeichnet
dass man immer weiß welcher schlauch zu
welchem regner gehört damals draufstehen
regner 1 und das machen wir drauf hier
ist ganz ganz wichtig alle schläuche
führen zu den zielen und die ventile
werden eingespeist von zisternen das
heißt alle schläuche die wir jetzt nach
vorne um das ganze haus verlegen werden
nachher hier landen und die haben
nachher unser unserer gartenhäuschen und
da unternehmens gartenhäuschen aber die
ganze ventile hin weil die ventile macht
man meistens dorthin wo sie nachher den
rasen roboter oder oder liebe die den
rasenmäher nicht stören und da können
wir einfach hinstellen und da können wir
nachher dann ein brett drüber machen
oder oder irgendwas schöne verzierung
und deckel drüber machen und das sieht
man ja auch nicht mehr und alles perfekt
und jetzt geht es um die redner und zwar
ist immer einfach die regeln anschließen
und zwar auch mit zack zack genau und
die redner so weit wie möglich an die
rasenkante direkt an die rasenkante man
muss natürlich auch darauf achten dass
direkt und genauso hoch wie der rasen
sind das nur später mit dem rasen
roboter und dem rasenmäher drüber fährt
dass man den köpfen nicht abrasiert
sozusagen
aber das kann man nachher wenn man wenn
man jetzt die ganze fläche mal richtig
eben gemacht hat kann man es noch ein
bisschen feinjustieren das ist gar kein
problem
und das alles mal plan machen und da
kann es noch ein bisschen justieren und
dann kommt eigentlich schon der rasen
drauf form rasen wollen wir noch
vielleicht ein automatischen mähroboter
machen nur noch legen immerhin trat aber
das zeigen wir euch einem anderen video
und jetzt um alles wieder einfach zu
schicken oder reinhard alles zu schütten
perfekt
[Musik]
jetzt sind die ganzen versorgungsleitung
von den ganzen von unserem ganzen garten
sind jetzt hier
ich finde es auch cool dass wir es
beschriftet haben das macht uns alles
leicht gemacht ist auch immer wieder
dass sie nicht durcheinander kommt ich
weiß nicht ob er auch daheim so eine
riesen garten hat ist gibt sehr viele
die so einen großen garten haben und
deswegen immer beschriften und jetzt
haben wir diese ventil boxen und hier an
die wm boxen die ventile boxen sorgen
dafür dass die ganze beregnung
geschaltet wird
und die haben wir schon ein bisschen
montiert hier könnt ihr mal reinschauen
das montieren ist ganz easy also ganz
ehrlich ist ganz ganz einfache
geschichte
jetzt nehmen wir zum beispiel des rechts
hier schneiden muss einfach abmachen he
nl verbinder und daneben die ventile
rein und bevor man jetzt ist alles hier
machen dass man im rhein abgleich ist
natürlich wichtig das wäre schon ein
gartenhäuschen aufbauen also wir bauen
jetzt das ganze gartenhäuschen auf
gucken dass alles frisch und dann muss
man auch nachher ganz genau wo diese box
nach hinkommen und das nächste schritt
ist natürlich jetzt den garten meinung
zu gestalten
und wenn alles steht schließt muss an so
einer testphase jetzt war es eine woche
nicht da ja wohin der woche ist saumäßig
passiert wir da am samstag haben wir im
ganzen trupp zusammen mit der ganzen
familie alles eingepflanzt und du siehst
ein bisschen was wir gemacht haben und
jetzt so gewesen natürlich habe jetzt
letzten zwei tage haben sondern
gepflanzt häufig montagen letzten zwei
tage bin ich das ganze haus gelaufen und
mit dem schlauch und die haben von
gegossen hat ich muss aber ehrlich sagen
hat spaß gemacht okay es war ein
spannendes zu gießen
alkohol wirklich bin eineinhalb stunde
und da gestand habe den ganzen garten
überall verbessert aber ich muss sagen
das müssen nicht jedes mal machen und
damit ich das nicht jedesmal machen muss
haben wir ja ein bewässerungssystem
gelegt und dieses bewässerungssystem das
werden jetzt anschließend zwar geht es
hier um diese topf leitungen
das ist eine top leistung und ungefähr
alle 30 zentimeter ist da ein loch drin
und zwar ist eine membrane drin da kann
auch nachher nix rein wachsen und die
top leitung kann man jetzt unterirdisch
legen dann sieht man die schläuche nicht
immer nichts oberirdisch bei uns wird es
jetzt nichts ausmachen bei wir haben
bodendecker gepflanzt überall mal
erwachsen nachher pflanzen drüber aber
trotzdem welche kleidung unter wasser
unter die erde legen
und da kommt ungefähr einer stunde wenn
wir die anlage anschließt in einer
stunde kommt pro loch ungefähr 1,5 liter
wasser raus da ist ein druckminderer
dran der dann den druck regelt und diese
leitungen werden jetzt ums bett komplett
außen rum legen um die pflanzen genau
oder genauer sind gespannt und ein 25 30
zentimeter ungefähr dann ja so dass jede
wasser jede pflanze was abbekommt und
dann ist es mit tipptopp sein
hier haben ja vor einer woche ungefähr
unsere wasserleitung gelegt dann haben
wir inzwischen stück dieses zwischen
türk hier dieser druckminderer der tut
die wasserleitung auf 16 bar unter
drosseln und jetzt tun wir über all
diese tropf leitungen anschließen gucken
wie ungefähr die pflanzen liegen das
ganze bett legt liegt und dann kommen
sie ein paar nur anstöpseln das anstösse
ist auch total easy das ist nur hier und
darauf stütze und deshalb bombenfest
perfekt
[Musik]
so um den bau machen ungefähr zwei top
leitungen der braucht ein bisschen mehr
wasser
und wenn man ein stück macht dann muss
man darauf achten dass man nicht direkt
hier am loch macht sondern und wo hier
perfekt das machen wir das hier drüber
und knicken dass so ein
und zack das reicht schon
man muss sich aber zeigen wenn man etwas
nicht funktioniert hier sehe ich hier
zum beispiel habe ich einen knick
reingemacht in den schlauch das darf
natürlich nicht sein sondern natürlich
keinen punkt nach auf der leitung kommt
kein wasser mehr durch deswegen bin so
was vorkommt aber nicht schlimm
und da gibt es eine ganz einfache lösung
und zwar schneiden wir einfach mal ab
und gerade an dem dicken schlauch und
dann machen wir hier ein l verbindung
ein
das war schon so jetzt auch einen krieg
raus und jetzt kann es weitergehen
aber wie gesagt keine panik kann mal
passieren ich mache das auch zum ersten
mal der reihe das gerade hinten an den
ventilen der macht der drüse jetzt
manuell betätigen
jetzt sind wir gespannt so jetzt hätte
schon die tröpfchenbewässerung 1,5 liter
in einer stunde pro loch reicht
vollkommen aus dass der vorteile ist an
seinem tropf leiter natürlich auch du du
schwimmst keine erde werke kennt das ja
jedes mal wenn wir dem gartenschlauch
hingeht das unter den pflanzen die erde
weg geschoben wird kann hier natürlich
nicht passieren sondern ich finde ich
nur ganz ganz leichtes tröpfeln so und
das können nämlich alles zu machen hier
perfekt
ja ihr seht auch wieder um den baum
haben wir mit einer schlaufe gelegt weil
er braucht nur ein bisschen mehr wasser
so dieser baum ist eine typische stelle
wo muss ich mal überlegt nee da mache
jetzt vielleicht keinen tropfen wie
jetzt kann ich mal kurz ab und zu mal
ein ding machen mit dem schlauch machen
aber bitte tut mir gefallen
also ich bin so ein typ der wird das
wieder vergessen verstehe ich deswegen
schon dabei sein macht es wirklich
komplett und habt eure ruhe und überall
da wo die tropfen leitung jetzt die
löcher drin hat und bewässert seht ihr
dass sie zwar grad hier sind wir müssen
eine feuchte stelle und wenn es ungefähr
so in zwei drei wochen schauen würde
dann würde ich alles komplett bewachsen
sein
die sind teilweise essbare blumen hier
drin dann haben auch wieder erdbeeren
drin und wird nachher alles zu wachsen
keine stein wie sie sozusagen sondern
richtig natürlich gewachsen auch ein
toller platz für bienen für lebewesen
ganz wichtig beim garten dass man dass
man braucht man brauchen wir unbedingt
und deswegen eine richtig tolle eine
richtig tolle aktion hiermit mit den
bodendeckern und ich muss jetzt nicht
mehr gießen und ihr seht dessen ungefähr
100 meter schlauch an sonnen an an
sondern druckminderer könnte bis zu 200
meter schlauch an anschließen also 200
meter ist es gar kein problem
und dann braucht ihr wieder neues ventil
die schläuche sieht man nachher nicht
mehr oder
wir graben sie einfach immer ein paar
zusammen der schausteller rentner
optimal und er ist auch noch fit und die
gartenarbeit auch zusammen was wir auch
haben wir haben hier noch eine
elektroleitung und zwar haben wir hier
sowohl james williamson einfach sachen
die mir nachher draufstellen ist so ein
lampe und die tun zum beispiel abends
wenn mir eine ambientebeleuchtung haben
einfach die wende an strahlen sie noch
richtig cool aus also abends wenn wir
uns mal besuchen kommt da ist richtig
schön aus ok honig kommt ins kleine
besucher sonst wenn jetzt alle mit uns
versuchen kommt einfach machbar
nein kommt müssen sich besucher ich
mache euch fotos okay ich hatte nicht
[Musik]
wirklich eine coole geschichte jetzt ja
und jetzt gucken wir was die sally und
der rhein hatte gerade macht lassen die
sich da hinten die machen auch etwas
richtig cooles kommt kurz mit während
ich die trotz bewässerung lege ist die
sally mauern hätte auch ich mach können
aber es macht sie jetzt und das werden
wir uns auch oliven baum und um den
olivenbaum das wird jetzt ungefähr noch
so hoch gemauert und um den olivenbaum
jetzt auch schon eine besserung legen
das heißt wirklich ich möchte dass jede
pflanze automatisch begossen wird und
dass man nichts mehr denken müssen auch
nichts vergessen richtig ja genau
ja ich vergesse es wahrscheinlich dass
wird nach ein cooles hochbeet das
hochbeet und verkleiden mit einer
fassade sowie die gleiche fassade die
wir hier haben
und da haben wir auch schon eine
tropfende besserung reingemacht dh das
hochbeet wird auch automatisch bewässert
jetzt wollen wir natürlich auch
was machst du damals hier bis zum
arbeiten gekommen
so und jetzt haben wir ja hier die
ventile und die ventile können ja
momentan per hand geschaltet werden aber
ich möchte das spiel das heißt
automatisch funktioniert und so haben
wir ein kabel von dem ventil boxen haben
wir ins gartenhäuschen gelegt und da ist
unser smart home system wo ich nachher
mit meinem handy das ganze haus die
ganze besetzung auch steuern kann und
die installation dieser ganzen boxen ist
ein relativ einfach da kann man nichts
falsch machen
das ist auch kaum strom drauf ist also
ein stromschlag durch sein auch nicht
kann auch nichts passieren und wenn wir
hier nach der gebrauchsanweisung mit
kann man selber machen aber ich
persönlich würde es noch jemand dazu
nehmen der sich damit auskennt richtig
keiner genau
gelb oder komplett
[Musik]
wichtig ist natürlich auch mal so eine
dokumentation zu machen dass man hier
wirklich die ventile bezeichnet hat zb 5
tropf werden tropfen dass der nord
hinten 9 ist trotz hoher rabatte süd
baum eingang und elf wert zb gt200 rasen
sieht das war hier vorne perfekt jetzt
habe ich hier noch smart sensoren und
diese smart sensoren die messen die
lichtstärke die bodenfeuchte und die
außentemperatur und die machen jetzt in
drei stellen rein
so kam ein smart grid system perfekt auf
die äußeren einflüsse und das wetter
reagieren so die redner die ventile und
die ganze kommunikation ist komplett
installiert jetzt heißt ich will mich
nur einen knopf drücken und das machen
wir hier mit sack und jetzt geht's los
hätte es komplett gigantisch oder
normalerweise laufen meine rechner immer
morgens um 5 uhr saßen sie eingestellt
nacheinander immer 20 minuten aber ich
merke es ist heiser und ich sehe einfach
es ist trocken da kann ich auch manuell
und ich kann es auch wieder manuell
einfach beenden
und jetzt hört es wieder auf genial oder
und manchmal kein irgendwie empfang ist
auch alles manuell steuerbar
so einfach geht's jetzt aber fertig das
meiste ist schon fertig hier der kürbis
will im sommer erwürgen wahrscheinlich
der hang und von der decke herunter im
schlafzimmer ja ja aber im prinzip
machen jetzt keine arbeit mehr im garten
außer ernten und pflegen genau und unser
traum ist in erfüllung gegangen
ein richtig coolen garten haben für
insekten für tiere für uns und sowieso
der alten garten genau und so wenig
arbeit wie möglich
dahinter steht es mit dem pferd ist hier
kommst du so genial und man hat genug
arbeit ums haus herum
von daher kann man sich das gießen und
bewässern sparen nicht automatisch
da kommt es schon so schön gespielt
haben wir zwei genießen die aussicht
genießen auf dich und auf dich auf uns
dann mit apfelschorle mit kirche
unser garten ist fast fertig die video
seht ihr alle auf meinem kanal und er
ist auch richtig schön geworden und wir
wollen uns bei unseren freunden und der
familie bedanken die hier alle fleißig
mitgeholfen haben
aber wir würden auch gerne mit euch
feiern das heißt die veranstalter eine
gartenparty
und weil hier nicht alle personen und
reinpassen verlagern wir das ganze nach
mauer und gehen da zum christian in die
baumschule zum lebensraum müller in maur
dass es bei wiesloch könnt ihr gerne
alle kommen die veranstaltung findet
statt am 13
und die uhrzeit steht hier unten ihr
könnt gerne vorbeischauen der moralist
mitarbeitern seht ihr ihn live wir dort
die pflanzen gießt ihr könnt uns fragen
stellen ihr könnt vielleicht auch fragen
stellen rund um den garten nicht
vielleicht ihr könnt auf jeden fall
fragen stellen rund um den garten wie
sieht's aus mit gartlehner
bewässerungssystemen was es mit dem
rasenmäher roboter könnte die frieda mal
im einsatz sehen
ihr könnt aber auch unsere anderen
partner kennenlernen wie kitsch und kann
wird gassi und sind auch mit dabei und
wir haben wirklich ganz viel viele tolle
sachen ich werde dort kochen und backen
oder grillen wir werden viele leckere
dinge zu bereiten eure kinder können der
mitnehmen denn für kinder wird auch ein
mega spass kinderschminke wird vor ort
sein vielleicht auch noch eine hüpfburg
vielleicht habt ihr auch noch weitere
ideen die ihr gerne unser das video
schreiben könnt dann freue ich mich
einfach auf euren besuch ich freue mich
euch kennenzulernen
lasst es krachen am 13 woran ist mit
dabei und mein ganzes team und wir
freuen uns schon auf euch gefallen